the insanity the rage the hysteria on
the left in America is reaching a fever
pitch this is not good for this country
now as we speak Democrats they are
plotting and planning and scheming to
overthrow the will of the American
people
remove this duly elected president from
office based on an outright lie now make
no mistake this is not an impeachment
proceeding in any way this is a
full-fledged political coup attempt
another coup attempt it is an
illegitimate unconstitutional clown show
but tonight the Trump administration
they are fighting back hard and letting
Democrats dig their own hole White House
Counsel Pat's abalone has now issued
what is a devastating takedown of the
Democrats latest attempted coup and in a
letter to Nancy Pelosi the Cowardly
Schiff and others Sippel only made one
thing perfectly clear the Trump
administration will not participate or
cooperate with the Democrats
unconstitutional invalid baseless
impeachment so-called inquiry and simple
only is right you must not legitimize
that which is illegitimate every
Republican needs to stand by our
Constitution the rule of law due process
past precedents and by the way how
Speaker Gingrich did it in the 1990s
against them President Bill Clinton
they're not offering anywhere near that
Republicans White House officials and
others must not participate in this
illegitimate unconstitutional madness
now let the do-nothing Democrats they
can own it all this is them this is who
they are in the end they've done nothing
for three years but hey Trump it's not
about truth it's not about law it's not
about a fact-finding mission this is yet
just another impeach and peach and peach
political witch on Byron York is
reporting today quote Pelosi won't go to
court to enforce the subpoenas who needs
it it takes too much time and they may
lose instead the house will keep
churning out subpoenas but impeach Trump
based on what is known now which is
nothing plus obstruction and an article
there on which covers the unanswered
subpoenas quick no fuss and peach fins
like McDonald's you're in and out in a
minute
now before digging deep into the
Democrats political strategy and how the
White House Counsel Pat's that baloney
took a wrecking ball to this BS inquiry
his words were devastating I'll get to
that we take a step back and we got to
remember how did we get here
because now there are three fundamental
things at play one the left in America
the Democrats the media mob they have
never been able to accept the truth and
the reality which is the results of the
2016 election - we had four separate
investigations into Trump Russia
collusion FBI house Intel bipartisan
Senate committee and guess what
culminating with Muller's report no
collusion impeachment dream shattered
three they know they can't beat Trump
even saying it
take a look are you concerned that
impeachment talk may actually help the
president's reelection I'm concerned
that if we don't impeach this president
he will get reelected if we don't
impeach him he will say he has been
vindicated
they don't impeach him he will win well
that's why we are where we are today all
started on the day when we the people
you the American voters shocked the
world and picked Donald Trump to be the
disruptive iconoclastic president you
elected the left couldn't believe it and
they snapped frankly and every day since
November 8th 2016 they have been engaged
with us in rage and hate and just fury
you know we the smelly Walmart shoppers
I'm guilty irredeemable deplorable
the ones that voted for Trump that are
clinging to their God gun Bible and
religion on November 9th look at this
Dallas Morning News this is what they
reported hundreds of anti-trump
protesters march in Dallas to rebel
against the election two days after
election a tenth of November 2016 fire
erupts vandalism reported an anti-trump
protest in Oakland thousands protest
Trump election in la blocked the 101
freeway downtown in New York protesters
return to return to Trump Tower for a
second night after Trump's big election
win
Louisville saw a not my president
protests the same day November
same story in Philly another protest in
Miami another one in Indianapolis and on
and on and on Democrats called for this
president to be removed from office
before he was ever close to being sworn
in and by the way they're compliant
friends the DNC stenographers the
conspiracy theorists liars known as the
medium mob they echoed all of this
hysteria on television follow the
timeline here watch this you may want to
run your DVR starting two days after
election day this is what brought us to
this point take a look if he takes the
risk of going to trial he's convicted
that could be seen as an impeachable
offense if Trump were caught on a video
camera snorting cocaine in the White
House maybe with one of his children
there was at least a chance he'd be
impeached if he's not legitimately
elected president you're mine there are
tools that Congress has I don't see how
that wouldn't be an impeachable offense
that tweet fits the Republican
definition of an impeachable offense I
will fight every day until he is
beachbody by grounds for impeachment
it's an impeachable offense perhaps in
peaceful offense is impeachment the
appropriate remedy something through the
Congress like impeachment all that maybe
in future way that's an impeachable
offense is that an impeachable offense
is that a impeachable offense to you
he's much more vulnerable to impeachment
a potential ingredient of impeachment
where do you see in a peaceful offense
it is grounds for impeachment
potentially criminal or even impeachable
grounds for impeachment or does that not
go far enough in your view grounds for
impeachment this tweet alone may be an
impeachable offense let's talk about
impeachment impeachment is on the table
which should be chable offensive bullies
do you see an impeachable set of
offenses it's an impeachable offense if
that's not impeachable I don't know what
is the president shall be removed from
office on impeachment is it impeachable
100% is impeachable very substantial
evidence that the president is guilty of
high crimes and misdemeanors grounds for
impeachment tipping-point
talk of impeachment reaches a fever
pitch on Capitol Hill and of course
there was the insurance policy in place
and it was called Operation crossfire
hurricane now it was the nine-month FBI
counterintelligence and only a president
can have that that would be Obama into
all things Trump and Russia Russia
Russia that came up totally empty Mt
empty even disgraced Trump aiding FBI
agent Peter struck admitted now there's
no there there and next there was the
twenty two months special counsel
witch-hunt in to trump Russia collusion
that came up empty to no collusion no
conspiracy nothing robert Muller's
biased testimony and embarrassment for
Democrats four separate investigations
cleared the president of wrongdoing but
no due process from that corrupt media
they've been pushing impeachment from
day one Democrats desperately seeking
searching hoping praying for another way
to meet demands of their radical base
they went from the stormy coup to a tax
return coup and now it looks like
they've settled on a temporary
manufactured scandal surrounding Ukraine
and to do that they got to ignore the
real scandal of Joe Biden and his son
and Pelosi made loud and clear Democrats
believe well there are many many good
options for P Qing the president oh we
just got to pick one out of a hat but
this time instead of relying on a
lengthy investigation to be thwarted by
a special counsel they're gonna take
matters into their own hands not gonna
make that mistake again and they'll just
use an unconstitutional impeachment
blitz as white House Counsel Pat
Cipollone II asserted in this brutal
takedown House Democrats have quote
designed and implemented the inquiry in
a manner that violates fundamental
fairness constitutionally mandated due
process they have denied the president
the right to cross-examine witnesses to
call witnesses to receive transcripts of
testimony to have access to evidence to
have counsel present and so many other
basic simple fundamental guaranteed
rights of all Americans now all this
violates a constitution the rule of law
and every past precedent yeah Newt gave
them all of that when they impeach
Clinton Cipollone II continues put
simply Democrats seek to overturn the
results of the 2016 election and
deprived you the American people of the
prend
of the president they have freely chosen
many Democrats now apparently view
impeachment not only as a means to undo
the democratic results of the last
election but as a strategy to influence
the next election which is
barely more than a year away and simple
Oni concluded quote given that the
inquiry lacks any legitimate
constitutional foundation any pretense
of fairness or even the most elementary
due process protections the executive
branch cannot be expected to participate
in this because participating in this
inquiry under the current
unconstitutional posture would inflict
lasting institutional harm on the
executive branch meaning future
presidents and today the president well
he called it rightly so a con
perpetrated against Americans led by
Schiff the Cowardly the wild sneaky ship
the lying ship and of course speaker a
name only Pelosi and the entire
Democratic clown show that his Capitol
Hill take a look he defrauded the
American public I mean honestly I don't
know what can happen but there are those
that say he should be prosecuted for
what he did he should certainly be
impeached also a big con don't you
understand look the phone call you have
it
it's the transcript that's why they keep
saying oh the whistleblower said this
and that what happened is if they would
have seen the transcript early they
wouldn't have had a whistleblower
because he wouldn't have said there was
nothing he could say these are crooked
people that are done these are Democrats
headed by a Democrat lawyer a big
Democrat lawyer there's a con job this
is a con being perpetrated in the United
States public and even the world the
cowardly shifty ship that he has the
transcript but it was well it exonerated
the president's we just made up a new
one
that's how pathetic and desperate they
are at denying the President of the
United States of America all right to
due process desperately trying to rush
impeachment across the finish line
without any real investigation without
any counter arguments without any cross
examinations without any evidence being
brought into the discussion they want to
do it in total secrecy and more
importantly there are no crimes there's
no treason no bribery whoa wait a minute
that's not true there is bribery
because Biden is bragging on tape about
bribing Ukraine with a billion taxpayer
dollars unless they fire that prosecutor
investigating his son
six hours son of a B they did it there
is no constitutionality no valid reason
for what is going on right now zero and
so far that hasn't even been a roll call
vote to proceed never mind
the rules the laws that are going to
govern this this circus this three-ring
circus of these Democrats why because
Pelosi is see those names pay close
attention she's trying to protect those
forty people those lawmakers in
districts that Donald J Trump won in
2016
those people know their days are
numbered if they go out and vote but
make no mistake those forty or so
Democrats they are complicit they're not
speaking out against this witch-hunt
so tonight it is imperative that House
Republicans follow the lead of the White
House Counsel what does that mean let
these post constitutional Democrats dig
their own grave and that means your
Republicans in the house must not
participate in any way in what is a
lawless unconstitutional illegitimate
process a kangaroo court a three-ring
circus
an unfounded political stunt and it's
time to give the do-nothing Democrats by
them their shovels let them dig their
own graves
let them scream and holler hem and haw
all they want now we can all watch them
spin out of control and Americans are
extremely smart they're very
sophisticated is smart enough to shop at
Walmart and Costco and save money
now people by the way know the
difference between an actual crime and
now a three-year political witch-hunt
that has done nothing for the American
people except divide this country my
message to you Republicans is you cannot
participate in an illegitimate
unconstitutional process let the
Democrats their allies in the media mob
own it sleep with it they can die with
it let's call the roll let's see where
they so-called moderate Democrats in
those Trump district stand Republicans
don't even bother to show up don't
participate in a lawless
unconstitutional illegitimate scheme
don't show up at the hearings you may
want to send one guy in a lawyer to take
notes don't show up on the House floor
or partake of none of this what
Democrats what do they value more well
not the US Constitution they have their
deep-seated hatred for Trump that trumps
everything no pun intended Donald Trump
cured cancer today didn't Peacham for
curing cancer this president is not
going anywhere the republican-controlled
Senate that's never ever going to
convict with 67 votes voters will see
clearly the great giant disparity
between the president keeping his
promises will scroll those and by the
way getting things done for the American
people and the soon to be chosen
Democratic challenger you got President
Trump has spent three years in spite of
this garbage this crap this witch-hunt
trying to and successfully improving the
lives of we the American people despite
constant resistance hysteria from the
left well take a look he is successfully
appointed to original Supreme Court
justices as promised he passed the
largest tax cuts in history as promised
he's cut more red tape and government
bureaucracy than any other president in
in a hundred years as promised we see
wages in America have hit a post
recession high jobless claims in this
country are the lowest since 1969 we've
seen record low unemployment for African
Americans Asian Americans Hispanic
Americans women in the workplace and
youth unemployment by the way we're also
energy independent for the first time in
75 years
on the other side America needs to ask
itself what of these Democrats this
three-ring circus of democrat what have
they accomplished the last three years
can you name a single thing because I
can't the answer is nothing
they have been totally consumed by utter
rage irrationality denial and it's one
political witch-hunt after another and
come November 2020 there will be a
reckoning Republicans you cannot
legitimize what is a sick ugly illegal
unconstitutional and what is nothing but
illegitimate madness don't show up don't
show up to the hearings don't vote on
the floor here's your mandate focus on
we the people that put you in office to
be servants be servants work to get
peace and security abroad and at home
work for job creation prosperity never
forget the Forgotten men and women of
this country